the microprocessor feature of the public
french and delighted to welcome you here
those of you who come from near and far
and I want to extend a special welcome
to our distinguished panelists today and
also thanks to Scott Lewis and also
incidence of services at the Embassy for
the miso processors you know has always
been an important point of contact for
artistic communities in France and in
New York and so I'm really happy to
continue that tradition today I won't
I'll be very brief
I just want to say two things
so first this panel is organized in as
you know in celebration and around what
I think is one of the most exciting film
movements in one of the most exciting
film series in the last few years this
is the free radicals this the series of
free radicals South Ozone and new French
cinema series that began on Wednesday
night and that continues through Monday
April 18th
so this series centers on films of a
collective of filmmakers closely
associated with the journal identity
scene you see a model and who spills as
Scott furnace says in a really wonderful
article in this month's film comment
those films are quoted as highly
original and formally and innovative as
any group of films circulating today and
I think that's really I can see
everything and I'm looking forward to
the series but what I've seen so far the
promo of their program skier
so make sure you have if you don't have
already the series are you funded on we
could Center Walter BTUs website and
also just for the question of language I
think we'll begin in English but French
is always an option and some people here
who were ready to translate
okay so my introduction will be brief
but I just wanted to identify so first
who's here as a graduate of the
everything nice her first feature-length
film is monkey mouse the walking man
which plays on Monday nights I believe
in the in the film series and has won a
number of very distinguished prizes
including the Grand Festival
Benjamin is a full sphere studied with a
French director of whom yes I was self
goes on assistant director for several
films including lots is the director of
common gooseneck which tomorrow he is
also a composer and do both the music
for set above all to compose the music
for social boss which I have to say is
the most extraordinary wartime musical
advocacy music and is also expensive
as here worked for a number of years as
the assistant director of
domini laus and then everyday and as
we've also made a documentary on their
work and now they're making donuts which
actually that film is screening on
campus somewhere next week
that's how
he's the director of several films two
of which will be screened at the Walter
Reed theater so the days that don't
exist there will also be three films by
cell phone calls moths which is tonight
at 6 p.m. so if you start meeting at
5:30 I know why you're which is in
addition to his works at director so
Guzman has acted in several films
including hex-head book fails the
Wahlberg family which is part of the
series and he's also written on cinema
and then that would be seen you might
have to eat vertigo and KDC you know and
I should add that part of the
originality of the film series this week
at Walter Reed theater is that there
will also be the screening of several
film program including chocolate
yes and
found which is tonight at eight and a
one more node in that cellar so it's
also DJing
tonight the right there so mention that
and then for the discussion for some
critic and programmer who contributes
regularly to film comment to develop the
slant magazine series anthology
the form of them that I hit Village
Voice and LA Weekly and is now associate
director of programming as society
Lincoln Center and a contributing editor
at fellow comments and stuff missus
press responsible for bringing this
fantastic series and to New York and I
was thinking too
I think may be a good place to begin now
we basically got where Aransas to
actually talk a little bit about
electric cinema and how it was formed
and what the timing principles were
there was a use it was that one line was
a certain group of filmmakers or I was
particularly interested in a search
would be good person to start talking
about that
so in france we used to have three
prizes repeat we dilute with reprise
which still exists
okay Tommy go which was law still exists
and another one it doesn't exist anymore
which was called the gray Josh and Josh
Sidhu was the freshman cadet from the
front in the fifties communism very very
entered by some of the initial critics
because he was very much against for
ideological reasons people like cramming
like flow I goes anyway Emanuel's you're
all friendly producer get back the price
in the in 1995 he occupies I don't know
how and so we decided to have a small
even proof for loop of this mission just
to select the movie and write a small
catalog for each year's selection and
that's how Lynette Emma began in 1985
are the smaller almost fencing like
magazine develop just one issue player
for the forthcoming vice and then in
1996 there was a first positive with no
publisher will magazine and then we
found publishable ballpark budgets
villains who also owns happy another
magazine for the place - the name and
which which is still running and at this
time the edge of the latest Emma was
three people so Emmanuel could be shot
that I just talked about and also she
Jamison who was a film critic and became
who is and was a film director and also
a critic and was produced at this time
by Emmanuel those are really guys
really
funnily and make that it was not video
show much more easily helpful them I so
now concerning the line of latest him up
who conspired against regularly as a
three monthly magazine and so it began
in 1986 and and the end was 2005 to
almost 10 years and we are not really
alive it was like a schizophrenic Maxim
because there was true life when I was
very modernistic like installation
geladas garden
yeah weak stuff it was championed by
Paul Ignazio Joe massara history you and
there was underlying language which is
not a lot of people who invited a more
smoothly
it's a job and where we wrote about all
fear my museums that yeah it's being of
light would be difficult that is my
manipulation so perhaps somebody did you
all actually was it truly magazine that
you met each other I did you and you
know each other before I was this what
am i nice cool and you already Excel
also angel animate also before no
accepts some other people
we already usually ever anybody wants to
speak to it did you feel that the
magazine was was there a certain boy in
French song criticism that my letter to
cinema was filming I mean since there is
traffic was he what
you know maybe more than joy a bit of
line that sort of a way to get it was
the essence was of the writing in this
natural after the initial impulse was
very simple it was that they came to see
the map I have stopped long ago to be a
magazine for people won't make movies
there is a kind of special energy that
you can find in some magazine when you
feel that the people involved I really
want you movie I really want to direct
some movies that's the case for the
Annika air bath but the case of Civility
during a certain diamond in New York
with the judge Nicastro desist is anyway
so after the bike was this really is
import and also
we have the kind of distaste for several
type of film directors that well well
really chocolate by everybody in France
so I should explain the question is what
to do with after the French beware with
a pesto pasta will look like is
considered an identity don't dishonor
the cost as modalities ontogeny Renee
Feeney Batman
so the question was the relation to the
dirty with and like a stopper is a
fabulous yes because I see it was the
father
this year the festival at all and what
to do with with narration narrative
energy it's going to festivals as
anonymous necessaries for some beasts
they neutral it but he can easily
committee whatever and what
victory and it's definitely take that
sorry anybody know situation it's the
Manya various sort of you know sketchy I
thought I may see you you know Betty Lou
think it is okay if you planning for
showing up so that mistake last even
eight that we need it was then a strong
example for grounded Brian for rounded
thoughts for others the width of
dialogue for grounded rupture as a kind
of game within posture everything that
was right early is what I try to do
how does one bring how does one break
the tone to inject humor into into into
the film itself is from the Victrola
Dorsey extra sleep damage to make the
seat thighs on a maybe NFL to remember
you the biggest
especially under our wings was the the
guy dies there is a very very sad and
moving scene and just tense politics in
that is very very comical scene and
nothing is lost in terms of the nests
are in terms of
well because you mentioned boxes Meharry
right there maybe you can also I see
something about that what is the
relationship of this group to the
certainly Domecq my own and maybe for
people who don't know what is the
listserv brother Mack mom you can say
something about that people know in the
late fifties early sixties there was
this whole small move of significant
friendships pioneers who added a cinema
called the McNally and this group was
directed by a guy called Commission was
very influential in the states too and
they are they acquiesced in like the
champion the obscure makers at around
which were not discovered by the casual
like ume tuner the first loser movies
like matado
like eat a video movies
I could go on for hours so no ice I keep
the French again because it would be
Toby get out of the way so this also mr.
MacLeod yeah
Santos really difficult I music oh
that's funny a second if I saw Thomas
edit value' book about having this a
better say some things obviously by
example the record of many struggle by
how much that I should take also Exodus
by Henninger Eastern trumpet by about
the Indian epic of its nominee all those
movies something income and also every
run of lagboys
yarmulke the uniform that's a strong he
also the animal is like that what when
we are going to show true analogy
filmmakers called Texas partners yeah in
from that actual human reflects our
chakras useful Adele
so this is the probable extraction in
these
that is not a modernist instruction I am
a mom clay the human from the same
website which gives for the film's sort
of abstract serenity a on a strong
belief useful class people have it
allowed me to develop it as small and
one has the impression when has the
impression that the film's are almost
carved in stone or perfect marble but at
the very limits of ratio this is what
else would I be - but that's not things
that won't your Hall Pass adventure
films for children young people the
message to 10 times what I'm kidding
a necklace name of it and there's
something the passive element of the
exact item to remove the resonator is a
cycle they come in virtually any better
so they say if the Knicks your
possibilities come from that to learn if
you if you come for example his last
bill that are mechanical also government
even workplace it's a depth at he
figured who who female efforts of
detainees the any specific order
I don't know and distant trumpet you you
see this
seems to be almost enhanced at the time
to Miriam in a second but I just said
the mention of the few aerial elements
of those films it reminds me something
that to someone in the audience man says
John Charles last night at the FL
society which is that a lot of the films
of this series actually have a scenario
totally filled with death in some way
and they oppose that a comment on the
death of cinema and I thought that that
led to an interesting discussion
actually about how about these stones
actually being in a way at least for
usual wrong maybe you can talk about it
anyone else who wants to say no actually
reaction against the idea of the the
death of cinema which is forbidden I was
was widely written about a time and
popularized by any number of critics and
some filmmakers you know it was within
the last decade or two decades and maybe
fifteen years old
there was a sense coming from filmmakers
number filmmakers but Tony Fadell
particular that there was a desire for
the death of cinema and in Google's case
there was a desire that's in a moment to
die after him
and of course material Casey nice
little sister seemed to just ask you
something to shoot into what it's been
what a cinemas assets is to have made us
more critical words that sound mice that
have little expression we're sensitive
to a vigorous style into a bombastic one
to reverb rather than to the adjective
to intention and movement or the to
sensation in stage
and to the world rather than just some
nebulous because imagine and I think you
can use that for the criticism that
they've been is so valuable but also do
a reaction to in the United States it's
a very very interesting would very much
would even vegetable desk
so I did that mr. button good if I don't
I could still call a decision yet so we
only comes that
I actually I'm interested in surrendered
you know technical question anyway which
is that when you when you mention the
hourglass it reminds me that you know
with one of the challenges are putting
the series the others that many of those
fellows have a unusual running time you
have films like mods and the early owns
the idiot that or one hour you have
assemble films like a 12-11 Teresa's
neck that are about 45 minutes long and
then you know yes you have Jean Charles
Phil it's three hours in ten minutes
and I'm wondering if this is all this
completely coincidental or there's a
reason that the length of the film seems
to be very malleable for this film
collected just one well the movies
what I wanted to say about that is that
it's it's in a way unusual but it's
where we get a sign of freedom but it's
also
you're suffering in a way because it's
hard to release those pills myself about
the length of my movie it was just like
the iodine we will like or somebody like
toy stash
this might also be a way of getting into
you know the the fact that these films
in some cases have not been very widely
I seen in France or even released in the
case of I did not die not released yet
and maybe you know we can talk about
some of the some of the producers some
of the festival's organizations that
have been important to making of
supporting these films you were telling
me a little bit about the SP which i
think is not something that people know
very much about in this country an
association of filmmakers and existing
for almost 20 years and they're our
first goal was to help other the other
film directors films to be released the
point of acid is to help
the films and to accomplish them than to
make discussions after films to help you
know them being distributed and for our
over 15 years
which is you know one of the series that
you can see the Cannes Film Festival
Oh Oh
my thumb where it was crazy first and I
see that and then you know in other
sections of major onward the second and
third feature films were screw other
sections but often I see to have this
option to have it's a bit or maybe
moreover the more free and that's how
films of when our could be shown and and
then supported through distribution in
France
it's about independent cinema and it
doesn't how there's not a school of
masses you know it's just just do it's
just whoever a directory can remember
and I support other other other things
where they love that's that's what it's
about
this is something that I'm not asking I
have no idea I'm gonna worry about some
of the ways that you found funding for
yourselves
that's amazing
I'm really impressed by perimeters that
wall to nowhere or shall we let's go
because it's such a mystery which family
here on somebody s my presence
really mister she makes the longest
movies with a
by disaster
so my only secret
it's a fix at all
with my
okay
so
so now you know
real necessity for the film to come out
because I feel
I need two accountants like my mother's
but once the film is made I'm very happy
I'm not concerned so much with the
release of the
chuckles always to be asked about the
police
oh yes sorry the most important part
I mean it's safe place 200 years
sometimes someone can screen
Japanese then Brutus and I should also
add that his film made in 2008 having
its North American premiere Sunday at 5
and I think it's a really remarkable
masterpiece it's definitely the most
ambitious
series and it's like to ask a little bit
so just to clarify what I just said was
very circumstances made my pleasure
one example is just that you
produced by the ttrt and I was a kind of
Siri and one of the director
the 15 directors but one of them
disappeared and 16 so I've been caught
ah just to go back actually something I
mean we talked a lot about you know
that's filmmakers schools of criticism
and I'm wondering if this particular
seems to be particular affinity between
these films and literature in the sense
that or Elias show is about a writer and
about region literary circles and moths
has this running discussion about sort
of you know intellectualism versus
physical forms of Fowler improving one's
worth and Jonathan John Charles fellow
at the Bates I know exists is is
inspired by a short story by myself I'm
a there was a bit self inspired by some
notes in a journal by Nathaniel
Hawthorne so can you talk a little bit
about this this rap war
so just one more word on this ideal of
filling done quickly in fact dream of
being employees of a major studio the
thought that one could make one or two
bigger allows for certain freedom and
perhaps to make
I did
- four years could seem very long the
fog is fine even with the French
production now we worked with for four
years production companies
so but they are waiting source
part of that way is there
except maybe a little bit on the writing
sometimes they would invest a little bit
of a rewrite he would save a part of I
know a lot of public funding
regional funding and distributions
disagree with that
special shout and pop tonic is John
Donne that doesn't like food Wow
good not even English survived but
everything yeah
stable actress panic destiny my destiny
steady up will get laid eyes on put out
and east question we might be at about
the biggest advantage
generally the compassion for say
me so as soon as we're going home as
soon as a written English
narcotic sales positive nine o'clock did
you receive video at Westeros many
others
so we often say this
but in the clarity of the
such a bad people misses she hasn't
smaller cut due to be able to say she
will fake something that was existing
municipal so one of my favorite
and you know yeah
Sedona Yahoo bottom are super Callie all
so to look them all so they talk yep I
use channel in there
the cruisers and the Masonic thing so
what difference would focus that
pedestrians are always in society and
about people who are in society our
films are for the most part of a social
characters very social
sloppy trail shelters and this the way
Google becomes one the culture versus to
declutter
Cheryl it's a political city the exact
term Oklahoma
there
either back home soon
the search of happiness Tuckerman every
donor for somewhere
the most common most potentially
dissolve the necessity of social
determinates also company
I also like to records I'll stay
it's also very appropriate because God's
first his first major government bill
society was a complete nervous
and now he's doing this very impressive
I'll say I'd like to read this book from
her house that I think is related to
something I said last night about again
this production yeah and something
related to film the days I don't exist
which someone is there
and he talked again about the lapse in
between he was so interested in on
cinema and that it's related to the
lapse in between one films and necklaces
and and one thing that's interesting is
even though the talk of the frustration
of that long gap between films is
brought up it's not like someone in
Hollywood who's just waiting and then
again isn't a new movement but that was
mature doesn't have an awesome I did not
die
we see in them the lesson so the
criticism has continued in that gap and
so later it comes here it's not a
continuation but there are new lessons
and
I think one of the things where you
really see the lesson is
if there's criticism but it's very
serious
it's not just quoted like a Tarantino
it's not just looking at other films and
making references and illusion
to illustrate this quote from Aaron Haas
I know of no other director who was more
indifferent to plasticity but his
shooting script is more ordinary for
shooting script is worth there but in
exchange who's more sensitive to being
that outline of a movement to its exact
duration and I think in these most
mature works
it's what's most remarkable at these
very subtle things I think about
the framing and editing
all of those lessons
between is there and I did not die it's
a very mindful that the lessons that we
mentioned some American lessons is that
first of all but I see also
and a dog and Rene and but the familiar
shots like a shot on the balcony around
a bed or on the sand but it's very
familiar with in extended
and because it's it's very I think that
question is movement with a captain
machine whom I guess what everything is
about that that group
you destroy your ship there is no
Charlotte that's I love bicycle program
I saw I love my school
I love manually done I could put a lot
of pain with at least enjoy because when
I try to escape them versus movies I try
to do back basics with the same
and Joe Charlie's family directly we
deal with without school and I also
invariant
and recognize they tell you basically
impossible at but something happens
especially with the economic importance
of the the worktop super-yummy specific
with the special message we use it
without yet
so that something happens I like how
could I tell the length of the film it
develops the voice of his own
well I've media for Evangeline
quietly here and and for search to talk
a little bit about the the role of music
particularly in Sturgis tones a little
Walmart family is music rich film some
of these films every buildings expense
it's not exactly to rely but because of
the various thing I think in mods that
law process that kind of disconnect
between the period of the music of the
Creator was a little odd but really a
witness taking place that could be
certainly a music of the sixties the
interest in in the musical form and why
this kind of music put into this
historic moment first available there
continued in the traditional Australian
whatever
this mystery until a case of yours and
the question of the relation between
movies and photos and what I feel very
interesting that was well I agree that
there is a deep connection very natural
connection and that usually Buddhism is
very pure business movies and people
everywhere but if you look now at the
photography I think that the dream scene
where is sleeping and it means that he
is flying with this dead girl those
things are not very good so why because
precisely tries to illustrate directly
something that is much more deeply
naturally Souta
so I think by opening this movie this is
shown romance with a momentum with
Tiffany we are listen Alabama and mystic
because Tiffany was fulfilling the
prophecy
he could has a strong I mean you know
button elevations with beta beveled the
conversation was the DePriest brought to
sustain in special heaven fundamentally
there's something much stronger those
but I present yesterday by this Western
history difference product edition eggs
for polygamy it's going to wonderland
those particular people who can only
move more real estate doesn't in Mesilla
care
she introduced pathological photo and
these these things are closer to what is
proper to others
the moments when he tries to eject go
see chemistry today that's what your
area we see what about yellow
what a music I might possibly die I
cannot answer about the roar of the
music in your parents I can only talk
about my experience with you because it
was kind of sixties very obscure song
English type of music called
all the country like the king's men that
the king's men the king's men mm glass
of inspector had all the things you can
find on the verbal population it's like
a fairy tale
not hire widows from any saturated
Victorian a second on television and so
stash asked us to give us some lyrics
various friendships and we had to find
some some church and maybe work together
to try to fit with what they wanted for
the movie and one of the things too
all the instruments of the music which
was our reference because that was the
outside is that with the drums with bass
and electric instruments and we knew
that we the music should be played in
the middle of nowhere
the nature with four instruments who
will - but who made insurance like my
audios really go wrong and even afford
it was a bad shot a visit and was it
wouldn't be big instruments in there
because of course it was to hide what
you're supposed to hide the position
generally yes we've also found a piano
in one second
so we have to deal with this kind of
things and the results of course some
smoke I think because of the harmonies
and because we try to be
mystical music
you know
the key is that for electricity though
the musical artists also would mention
our Lincoln Mencia twisting the first
the first
the gear is also their cousin community
Milty autopilot so one of the one of
those specificities of music and art
films is that there's no real music from
outside music in our feelings always
plays a significant role in the
narrative even if this music is sad you
can kiss music's melancholy it gives the
force a certain force back to the naira
to the narration of activist story of
the film
one example is moths went missing
character against well music
when you connect first small in suggest
the de cuarto de use the music velocity
when well as possible possible correctly
cushion and a psychotically a or photo
kind of magic fruit
music
yes correct
una vez una otra vez honker to see they
ask it if I wanna see astern of us who
survived protection
so this love of music art films reading
access to the love of certain Hollywood
films and also the diagonal movie
there's a love of song in their book
this is a what I want to present this
tonight if you want to receive the
masterpiece of Italy there is some
stinging anything because of like
everything is like this negative force
and when it's very but also is that was
right by giving this term Vicky was very
alone after exactly by trying to
continue this French musical tradition
it was very very old and what is
interesting is that it was as a young
teenager vehicles - Chris - Thomas -
even produced the first to shock movies
from stash with palmares you blew away
the shots but joyous - and particularly
when committee of the opposite side from
an ethical point of view and after the
first video of Colleen
trans - stop talking - panic a physical
birth so awful that is you dare to speak
he managed to speak with he became
physically because of that in France
there is a Maxima the best expedition
I mean with realistic stories ordinary
love story about other people and few
people except Italy try to escape to
take the maximum risks we naturally I
may say so the Kelly pass was the main
the main reasons began naturally it was
the only one to be so strongly on the
quality
they figure if I'm talking sometimes
food they move
I think because
I think you know add to this to see if
there's some questions for me the
audience but I I wanted to to ask
everybody actually a little bit about a
rather fascinating exhibition that was a
stage that the central poppy do last
fall by Sarah which I think everybody
participated it at one way or another
all the world over with
well I'll actually let Sarah maybe give
a background of what this was and I have
a deeply interested to hear people's
opinions about whether whether this was
a kind of an important moment in terms
of the profile of this group even though
it was not specifically about your work
feelings as I already told police to
somebody materials we didn't try to do
it as a way of showing our own wealth no
few mothers has been screened there that
fast as possible
on the contrary i made it with aschedule
that a fan of mine who also wrote this
extensively for electricity MA and who
is also a director and the idea was to
venture again so what I mean is when I
juice tomato sauce he said he said a
chakra the debate to the learnings
understand as much more accessible
instructional circumstance consciousness
law itself analogous term also
occasionally why I use this mortal man
here okay ladies it is dismissed
Romanian acidulous eternal stop
and to ask a question of the film about
Network the film II remember
specifically artisinal
so he began the example of the Kelly so
we had publicly leaving 81 years old who
made something on Sunday me on one of
the great team directors but not by
German to the habit but they specific
part endogenous movie which is calling
French will donate out the gift of Tears
I mean why nama the audience's was to
cry
at which moment what make them cry and
they supposed to type of manhood I'm
going to be that movie first movie
called smell / document which is a
masterpiece and I was there to talk
about
massive energy damages the way
monologues of the way the murderers of
vanilla we can postpone an affair the
same we turn on them and go hot mess
if you have seen this movie so we had
all these things running but also we had
a musical set also I made a very short
movie almost not a movie very very
minimalistic there which will be
swinging by Scott in Rosario but it was
made for TV and it's really really rough
there was also a selection of American
movies
McBurney movies
that's Lisa Valley the world knows our
subpoena met one young buck wants to be
seen as a ballet pushed back so the only
their failure as critic it was a no
mention to you need to Qaddafi who
Wakamatsu movie when people have to make
to be but such struggle because you're
going to be done you're going to die
they were asked and then follow the flow
and there was Sudanese video a song
almost during the post when before when
the body for them and it was all the
inspired question
was to sing every morning the program
and put into shows one was
a some conference about cinema the
thirties specifically the song inside
volatility Palestine and we there was a
conference and from time to time you
show clips or we sing the song and one
of the show was about Preston it was
actually show songs by a cabal another
question
what a thing
and
and if he got was the I wasn't the one
decade where there was not the day so
make her and they can live what because
was brought by sandwich was that
Patricia has a French film director who
directed sensitive and a couple of other
movies was to discover film clips of
five or six young film directors Freeman
is committed all clips and she had never
seen the film she just screamed and saw
three minutes is selected I think
themselves and she was supposed to ask
us in front of the audience you know
what why have you made those directing
choices and how we shot it and why did
we choose this bangle or this or this
way of shooting but without knowing
anything about the film so that was kind
of challenging interesting and we didn't
die after that son
for me that director was not heard yet
from you know I said how the thanks to
the actor Johnny stop moving
and
and then you know when you see it making
off what do you see you see people
waiting always if someone knows the
onset present acceptable you know this
very strange feeling that everybody is
waiting and never worked
so maybe the idea is that waiting is the
real work of making with him so he asked
me to do something but this insist I'm
really interested in
I think mr. movie the fact of waiting I
was very very happy with this because I
just wanted to see you Oh Louise Bob
here they all and many adoptable it made
new movies especially college and the
Russell movie it's a sham believe it is
I think 45 minutes long so it still I
was very that yeah the actress stuff was
not only I'm talking singing dancing but
by really making this for the original I
suppose Halloween's made a movie God's
apparently strategy French film director
and the movie of what we's is 52 minutes
don't vomit
very funny and very stretch or loop
alabaster samson tocadisco he always
believed on the vessel
mentality
so the
the show was a sort of verification of
the possibility of the last major or the
last major without much funding there
were nonetheless there were huge crowds
that came and there was a sort of deeper
pitch a creative fix that is to promote
usual because a potato
to me especially
the result
any questions questions from the
audience say yes
wanting to choose your actors are they
it's a greater power
no I thought about choosing the
actresses it's a matter of taste I think
enough of you know whether whether
someone well I don't think there was
much for my actor it was quite precise
and specific but he brought his own
talent and an invention that also
brought a special kind of enemy to his
own but I sort of opened up to that I
didn't think I would you know what I
didn't anticipate that I didn't think
you know he would bring that and it
actually brought a lot of the movie
without my really realizing or I was
only realizing it throughout making his
own but his own special kind of
tenderness
you'll understand that it's a paradox
because the the counter is quite
dramatic attractive and and the actual
broth is known the sweetness and humor
in a very delicate way which actually I
think it really enriches the character
for me it's it event that I must say
that I never
made what we call a caste
I did but most of time I want to feel
some
just because I like something we're very
open space and it could be a
professional first it comes from the
real person that inspires me
and
and concerning the freedom when I begun
I must say
there was no such freedom as
I think that freedom is something you
have to fight for
as far as improving
I don't know if we are also because God
made a permission about it but what
doing true because it's back is that he
used sometimes love same actors in our
movies vice opportunity a stock fell off
I don't know myself we all know this
movie and this is something I back
because when you look at what we can is
we be passing those movie I don't know
when you look at movies you are quite
sure that I don't have will have you
know it was personal
how will a deal with what Eric was -
what we're gonna be so it's very funny
and exciting because you know you are to
savato you know for a walk when I think
like that and they always change the way
they look and I especially like when the
like yourself down to type of actors in
my movie at least the friends and the
professional actors and I like the fact
that the
my own hair they can maybe some Desmond
who starts in the reveal sometimes
without sex sometimes I use that
asparagus my sister and that there was
one protocol to that I not told women
shut your custom web which I really
liked
specially the previous movies that's why
the party is and we could even for
Michael just because he plays without me
like confident in very Christmas movie
taxi is the the father of semi necessary
it plays a nested level with the new bed
anywhere in the beginning it was not a
professional I was never trained as an
actor is possibly was a kind of boutique
movie facade and then come on explain is
Kara which is exactly the finally never
married single
lady recently made a musical is not
professional in the traditional sense as
being having being trained to act of
school he was empiricism a doesn't own
place the devil the devil is the one who
kisses because the best people Esau
played by the back is one of the
question I see man and it was no fantasy
can explain tonight because it's an
obsession of Jerusalem where when you
meet him the first times always telling
the stories about the shooting of this
gala movie was PLA was a terrible
director I mean I mean the actor will be
and but when he was trying to play and
he was playing the part will get a
standing stones in the in his back so he
was and they said very good Gaston
because he is gay and they keep kept
dancing very very day after and so it's
been a little like it's his own
crucifixion if you talk about the PRI in
other
it's actually nice because they you're
one of the words that I always hear
people talk about these contemporary
Frankston and I mean the new way pushes
the word documentary so I guess I want
to be a little perverse and just ask you
you know what you feel about that
you know I hate like this mantra for
that but I must confess that I can say
so I have never seen a wise man movie
I've never seen one that would be I've
never seen like this who said that
I agreed to film or film is also
documentary all those actors show in the
United by Michael tell you
I think
the ice and flyers
yes and you can also see her in in the
idiot by Pierre Leone
actually maybe a nice way to direct the
snuff would be if everybody can say a
little bit about what they are working
on for their next project I started
writing and before shooting my first
film I thought I was being clever and
you know it
accelerated process that this was six
years ago so obviously this work and you
know starting to be in financing and
reverse movie in casting so we'll
hopefully we'll shoot it next year maybe
sometime if ever and it's very very
different for my first film that's what
I think it's gonna be like sending the
girl comedy so my first film is over 20
years in Paris of one's little character
and you know we sat in the second film
is three days in the countryside with
many characters and a sort of a comedy
so I'm trying to make the most you know
please difference but no way I'm sure it
will be the same when you're over again
as you know one always makes this thing
over and over again I mean all the time
short films trying to make a completely
different film and then after the same
again
I did not die is
but maybe kind of going to come up with
wrong at that I love seeing serials
series and I love be good maybe
I was from the same town and I love this
film continuing and even if it's not the
real simple
I let us also when we see the old films
you can has said see the same actors so
it's just like yes very big and
yes writing
prequels and sequels I did not die which
somebody said I was born crimes they
emptied my next movie every finger if
there is no matter what if Lincoln
especially yeah thank you
movie / - tick-tock mr. Ollivander it's
a kind of will define projections of
writing music